[Music]  football is a man's game right  yeah totally that's why we play women  are smaller so should they have smaller  goalposts through the hell after that do  you ever wear pink of course we wear  pink we're girls are there lots of Tears  in the locker room sometimes if you lose  an important game than my favor is  definitely not when the girls are angels  are tougher than the moon sometimes  doesn't your hair like get in the way  when you're running to the ball so are  usually my hair to the back of mr. not  really a woman would never get into the  men's team would they it'd be pretty  embarrassing if a woman showed up a  month does anyone actually watch women's  football while two and a half million  actually watch this at the World Cup at  midnight doesn't answer that one yet  should you be pleased as much as me  absolutely we're doing the same thing  aren't we can you be strong and feminine  at the same time I think that's the new  modern woman  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Music]